lessons i've learned how can you
increase your uploads
by the way if you go live and you cut
out some clips
you could go live one time cut out three
clips from that and that could be four
uploads you start thinking smarter and
not just harder
and not just grit and hustle but you
think about
strategy just an observation and we've
learned and that's
one of the things we're implementing at
think media is just
how do we keep quality high while
increasing quantity
hear me if you say well which one's more
important in my opinion
quality is more important i would rather
put out one good
good video than seven week ones because
i stretch myself too thin
too soon so what are the secrets to some
of the top performing
youtube channels here at think we love
to study not only our students
but other youtube channels that may not
be considered
youtubers out in the world meaning they
may be businessmen or women
and we love to study what they're doing
on youtube to become
successful you know what i love about
youtube so much is that it's not just
about
the viral sensations like mr obese but
it can be about
everyday content creators and people who
are making an impact
outside of youtube and bringing that
impact on
youtube and today we're going to be
diving into some lessons learned from a
youtuber with over 2 million
subscribers my name is heather torres
and i am your host
of the think marketing podcast the
number one podcast
to help you grow your influence on
youtube and then turn that influence
into a high impact and a high profit
youtube channel
if you're brand new to the podcast i
want to encourage you to subscribe
wherever you're listening to this
podcast from
and if you haven't heard our upcoming
grow with video live
2021 is right around the corner i'll
tell you more about that after today's
episode
but i am giddy with excitement of all of
the things happening this year at this
virtual conference
well let's get into today's featured
content with sean cannell
all about how this one youtuber has
impacted
our channel
[Music]
so i'm super fired up to share five
powerful youtube tips and strategies
that i think are gonna make a real
difference
in your channel your business and what
you're building
with youtube and i actually unpacked and
discovered these strategies
from dave ramsey now you've maybe never
heard of dave ramsey before he's pretty
well known in the personal finance space
but
um also kind of in his own niche and
definitely known
around kind of more of a conservative
audience and a very conservative
viewpoint
on finances he's kind of known as the
guy that will get you out of debt
debt-free scream anti-credit cards but
when it comes to youtube a lot of people
don't realize
even though he got his start on radio
and he's been in the game for decades
that his youtube channel has over 2
million
subscribers it has over 644 million
views and he actually has a second
youtube channel
where he does two hour live shows
five days a week that's where his radio
show streams on the radio
plus on youtube all kind of you want to
talk about multi-streaming you want to
talk about being live in multiple places
at once
and so he goes live for two hours a day
that channel
has four thousand subscribers
i don't mean anything by this comparison
but i just looked up how many people
how many google results show up for sean
cannell per month
and there may be another sean cannell or
two who knows but that's 373
000 google results and then i looked up
dave ramsey and it's 14
million 600 000 results and and
sometimes
tony or ariola on the think media team
and one of my hobbies
is to compare things on google trends
like sometimes we compare cameras so
we're like is the m50 more influential
or is dave ramsey more influential you
just type in like two different things
there
you know donald trump joe biden dave
ramsey or whoever you know he's typing
like different names it's kind of funny
so i type in like sean cannell uh dave
ran
sean cannell is a zero compared to dave
ramsey but dave ramsey's
he's got a lot of influence and that's
just to put it out there as far as
again maybe you've heard of him or you
haven't but no matter what you feel
about him whether you love him or hate
him
despite some even the controversy that
he's been in lately
none of that is really the point of this
episode the point of this episode
is real youtube strategies that are
going to help you
win that he models really well
on his massively successful youtube
channel and the first one is this create
a
system and keep it simple cool thing
about his youtube channel is he
basically has
one strategy we teach it here at think
media
it's called asq answer specific
questions what he uploads on his main
channel over 2.3 million subscribers
is clips of his radio call-in show
where people ask a question and he
answers it
or he answers it with one of the ramsey
personalities that he
rotates through his show and so
that's it i mean that's basically all
that's on the channel is him
answering specific questions one
question
one answer one video um he answers
audience questions now what's
interesting was i was able to actually
tour the
ramsey audience building recently the
office building he's got a thousand
employees right
it's a 300 million dollar building that
they paid cash for because they really
don't believe in credit
and uh it's pretty crazy everything that
they've built there and we hung out with
the entree leadership team which is just
the niche within the niche
where they teach leadership and we were
learning about
what they think makes a great business
which is also true i think about what
makes a great youtube channel
and we've actually having at the
beginning of the year we did a youtube
strategy session where we put this into
a phrase
and the phrase was the creator who
understands the viewer best
wins and when we were with the entree
leadership team what they were saying is
they said
what can often happen in a business
content creators
authors a church a pastor is they don't
really understand
who they're serving they don't actually
really understand
like they're making products that
nobody's asking for they're making
features on their products that nobody
wanted
they're marketing their products in ways
that are not connecting with the
audience they want to re
reach because they're not using the
right words and he said
the number one thing you should do in
your company and this was advice they
were giving us
is you should make all of your leaders
and all of your team
spend real time in conversation
with your audience in real time in
conversation
with your customers and they said this
they said you know the powerful thing
about dave
is he spends two hours a day talking to
the people we serve
every day five days a week super
powerful
years into his business he's still in
the streets if you will
in the trenches talking to people which
helps him
maintain empathy know where people are
at know the questions they're asking
and so he is super close to the people
he's serving and what they were also
saying is they were saying we got people
behind closed doors
we got leaders that are maybe coming up
with ideas
in a you know in a closed room that are
out of touch
with the people we actually want to
serve and help this is kind of a side
point
how can you get closer to the people
you're serving
but his his system is simple start at a
live show
go live two hours a time cut out clips
answer specific questions and of course
he's got to level up his craft and
formulate his frameworks and he's got a
whole business he's writing books create
courses he's doing all kinds of things
but number one create a system and keep
it simple what's your youtube system
how can you simplify it how can you just
create a simple system that scales
number two live streaming and
repurposing content
if you haven't checked out one of our
recent episodes of the think media
podcast we talked about
some of the new things we do at think
media that have been very powerful for
us
and i saw that this and dave's strategy
remember how i mentioned he has a second
channel with his two
hour live shows so he's got a second
channel
that's a much smaller channel by the way
now you might go i would kill for a 124
000
subscribers but in comparison to his 2
million subscriber channel
this is a lot of insight for me that
he's got his main kind of core audience
that want the long
content right two hours a day they're
subscribed to that channel
100 000 people but out of those episodes
then
they cut out the highlights and that
channel has scaled to the moon
because a lot of people don't want to
spend two hours with you but they might
spend four hours
four minutes six minutes eight minutes
so live streaming
and repurposing content he's created a
system
goes live a couple days a week now no
you might not be able to do that you
might not want to do that
for us at think media i do coffee with
kannel every other week
heather taurus does the youtube made
simple show every other week we
definitely don't do it every day
but even just going live then what we're
able to do is cut out clips
and a lot of times those clips do far
better than the show
itself this is a powerful lesson i've
learned from dave ramsey about youtube
success because he's using the content
in multiple ways
that content can also be extended onto
social media and it's helped him make a
major impact and i believe you could
figure out
how to if you can figure out how to
weave that into your strategy it could
really move the needle for you number
three
the power of a polarizing point of view
i love this i mean if you know dave then
you know that he's a polarizing person
and it's part of his power and he's a
great example of this because okay
he's in personal finance he's helping
people get out of debt
he's helping people manage money do you
know how many people do that
it's uncountable do you know how many
books there are on personal finance
unlimited do you know how many channels
and people you could follow it's endless
but one of dave's strengths is having
an actual opinion and a polarizing
point of view what do i mean he's
anti-credit card
and they live it from top to bottom at
their company
like you're probably not going to get in
trouble if you have a credit card there
but it's their value system
they want people out of debt they want
people not over leveraged
right and so they're living what they so
they're practicing what they preach
they know what they preach but he's got
a polarizing point of view
now think about it this way there's
another guy
personal finance his name's robert
kiyosaki rich dad poor dad you ever read
that book love that book love dave's
stuff total money makeover
and i'm maybe like a hybrid like i i
have credit cards do not tell dave
i i do use credit cards i know it's it's
but
i just do and i pay i keep the balance
paid off i understand i'm not even
trying to get off into a
rabbit trail here i i mean i i do like
the cash back like i'm
sorry i'm sorry i feel like i have to
defend myself dave
there's no way he's watching this but
anyways but you got you've got rich dad
poor dad
what's his his belief he leverages
like crazy real estate like flipping
real estate to pay for real estate to
pay for real estate
they've both been wildly successful i
went to a rich dad poor dad event once
and the speaker this is kind of sketch
the speaker
was like he was telling us to buy mobile
homes and flip mobile homes
okay and and he said and we're like well
we have no money for this and out of his
pocket i kid you not he pulled out a
stack of credit cards with a rubber
bound around him and he goes and he's
like this is how you're gonna do it
and this is back when they were just
giving out like zero percent apr credit
cards
and he was like you could build a a real
estate mobile home empire with a stack
of credit cards
and my wife and i were like what is
going on like this is scary
so i mean i'm like i'm not anti-credit
card i'm definitely anti-that but you
know
somewhere in the middle but here's the
thing they have
massively different polarizing point of
views and
and robert kiyosaki is doing great
dave's doing great why are both of them
doing great they're both
loud about what they believe my question
for you is what do you believe
what is your polarizing point of view
that you can lead into not that you make
up
that you're truly convicted by i think
the reason why i respect both of these
guys
is they're living in integrity they are
bought they are sold out
integrity simply means a whole number it
means you're not
divided you're a whole integer you're
not
actually i'm kind of conflicted you know
why you do what you do i know my
personal discipline
in using credit cards to have enough
cash in the bank to be able to pay them
off and leverage the percentage
i don't feel like i need to defend
myself to dave even though i just did
and i know where i stand i know what i
believe and it's not very polarizing i'm
the vanilla guy in the middle that's not
willing to take a stand listen
what is your polarizing point of view
you know my polarizing point of view is
kind of offensive on a virtual event i
did the other day as i was like listen
it's irresponsible for you not to be on
youtube and youtube is the best social
media platform period it just is
like i was like it's the only platform
where your content lives forever
i just don't want to post day after day
after minute after minute and all these
other social media platforms
i love them i support them i want to
leverage youtube to build a systems and
a team around
so we can make a greater impact on those
platforms but as a solo individual
the best return on my time is youtube
i'll like you know live or die in l.a
for youtube like i mean
i gotta go youtube and so it's just
what's your polarizing point of view
and one of the things that's helped dave
cut through the noise and you'll notice
this
influencers that stand out make a stand
for something
influencers that stand out stand for
something
they're willing to pick a fight they're
definitely not afraid if so
if they call someone out call out their
viewpoint they say this where i stand
this what i believe
and and this can really accelerate your
youtube channel
not something you force and it's not
something that's fake it's when you go
deep on what are your values what are
your convictions
what are your beliefs and you build
your polarizing point of view
number four volume of videos
now these are just some lessons i've
learned from dave we can't all do these
immediately because this one's about to
make you spit out your coffee and fall
out of your chair
how many uploads does dave post per
month
well at the time of recording this the
answer is
82. it's pretty gnarly isn't it
82 uploads a month you know think media
we are a team
and we're on the way up we're we're on
our journey and tony ariola is our
executive producer and we're on our way
to seven a week that's one a day
and after this episode i'm gonna have an
all-team meeting and i'm gonna say
listen if we're not at 82 uploads
a month then you're all fired that's
just that's what that's the next
move i'm just kidding right but like
volume of videos
and we've often said that if you double
your videos you double your views
here's the question it shouldn't stress
you out it shouldn't make you say i'm
gonna stop sleeping that's where i'm
gonna get the extra hours i just won't
sleep no that's not the answer but the
answer
is thinking about okay how could i
instead of saying it's kind of like rich
dad poor dad would say
the way my rich dad taught me he said
don't say i can't afford it
say how can i afford it you know what i
mean don't say i can't do 82 uploads a
month say
how could i do 82 uploads a month dave
is not just starting
dave had a successful business before
youtube started so i mean
you got to give yourself some credit you
got to give yourself but 82
uploads there's a reason why he's
getting
16.3 million views a month
on his channel 5 308
uploads so far volume of videos
volumes of volume of uploads lessons
i've learned
how can you increase your uploads by the
way if you go live and you cut out some
clips
you could go live one time cut out three
clips from that and that could be four
uploads you start thinking smarter and
not just harder
and not just grit and hustle but you
think about
strategy just an observation and we've
learned and that's
one of the things we're implementing at
think media is just
how do we keep quality high while
increasing quantity hear me if you say
well which one's more important in my
opinion quality is more important
i would rather put out one good good
video than seven week ones because i
stretch myself too thin too
soon but i want to ask man how can we
keep quality high and increase volume
and by the way
i didn't even touch on the fact that
dave has personalities
so there's actually about like 10
channels in their network
and they're uploading on those channels
as well obviously
that's team that's more people that's
more systems that's infrastructure
this is not something you do overnight
but it is something you want to grow
into
so think about how that could apply it's
just the smallest level man how could i
go
from one upload to two what would i need
to do how much money would i need
who would i maybe need to hire what
would i need to delegate how could i
turn one video into two by just being
intentional
that could really help me get more views
grow my subscribers faster grow my
revenue faster
so i have more money for the mission and
then
number five and i also have a bonus tip
for you a sixth tip
but number five that i love in an
observation that
i see dave ramsey do and some of the
personalities the ramsey personalities
do that lead to
a lot of impact as i see i see them do
trend surfing
now if you're new to the think media
podcast super grateful that you're here
and i encourage you to go back in our
library and look up
the think media podcast episode about
trend surfing where we go deeper on it
but essentially it's where you're
talking about
things that are happening in pop culture
things that are happening in culture now
and i shouldn't even say pop culture
because here's how it happens for dave
ramsey
it's actually connected to his simple
system
why because someone calls in talking
about what's on their mind at that
moment
so right now at the time of recording
the housing market's crazy
people are like should i sell it keeps
going up should i buy right now
and so that is actually a trend
sometimes it's a lot more chill it's
like stable
no one's really talking about it people
are just doing what they're doing based
on what their family
but it's such a it's an edgy topic is it
too late is the bubble about to burst
it's what's on people's minds so
naturally
many of the videos that they'll talk
about in these simple asq
videos answer specific questions are
about
what is happening in the now moment so
dave will commentate
on the news on the economy on the
stimulus checks
on cryptocurrency on the real estate
market and because
he's trend surfing some videos
82 uploads a month some just impact a
few of the subscribers it's just a solid
video you know it's like a solid base
hit
but some are a home run and sometimes
when the bases are loaded
it's a grand slam because he hits the
right topic at the right time with the
right thumbnail and the right title
and that right moment and surfs a trend
i definitely encourage you for more
strategy and our favorite ways to spot
trends
check out that video in the archive of
trend surfing on the think media podcast
but those are five tips and i want to
give you a bonus one in just a second
and ask yourself again what's the next
right step for you
you know you can't do all of these
things all at once
and complexity is the enemy of execution
so we start with number one keep it
simple but what's a simple tweak can you
start a live show
maybe once a month and just repurpose
like you don't you could go live once a
month
and then repurpose clips once a week and
stretch it out over four weeks
like there's ways to make this simple so
that you can
go down the path of least anxiety go
down the path
of least overwhelm while using leverage
to create exponential results
but bonus tip number six um
that i've learned from dave ramsey about
youtube success
is that dave and his team and ramsey
solutions have built a business
that's bigger than youtube and you know
at think media podcast this is our heart
like more than anything
you know we help you with youtube but
our vision is to help you build a
profitable
business around your youtube
channel and we actually are going to be
going deep on that
at our eventgrowwithvideolive.com
because it's not just about the views
it's not just about the subscribers
but it's about what else have you built
around your
business around your youtube channel
that is in a real sustainable business
it helps for dave ramsey because he had
a business preceding
he's helping people get he had
curriculum books
nowadays he's got an app that helps you
save money it's free there's paid
aspects of it
he helps connect you with financial
service providers there's different ways
where he makes affiliate income
and connections that i mean a thousand
employees paid 300 million dollars
in cash to build buildings and is
building
a conference center so they can do
events on their property in nashville
cash they build at the speed of cash you
know
and so touring their property so what's
the bigger business you're building you
know youtube ultimately yeah there's
youtube ads amazing
right super chat cool affiliate
marketing brand deals
awesome but what's the bigger business
and the powerful thing is that all this
traffic
is he's on multiple platforms but
youtube alone 16 million views a month
crazy but what's really crazy is how
that
leads into other products and programs
and ip
intellectual property and so the
question i have for you
is what's the bigger business you're
building how can you build a bigger
business
that is not dependent on youtube that is
not
all about youtube but that's about the
legacy and the impact the problem you
solve the people you serve
who you help and how you help them and
something that can outlive
youtube and if you want more help with
that i want to encourage you
don't miss our event grow with video
live um we
are going to be giving you the latest
strategies on how to get views and how
to grow your subscribers and of course
how to really crush it on youtube but
then how do you connect those
strategies to build a real influencer
business and my definition of influencer
is a thought leader business if you want
to be an author speaker
coach consultant online course creator
online marketer
if you want to be an influencer i think
about the influencers of
old are those like marcus aurelius
i don't know why he came to mind first
you know plato you know i'm talking
about like greek philosophers here
uh you know talking about abraham
lincoln and i think about like lincoln
on leadership and different books i've
been
like influencers people who influenced
culture people who influence the world
and if you listen to this podcast maybe
you want to write a book
you know maybe you want to create a
course maybe you want to teach what you
know maybe you want to be
paid for your expertise maybe you want
to solve a problem maybe you want to
create physical products and build
online businesses
there's so much opportunity in the
creator economy
over this next decade and at growth
video live we're going to be going deep
and we're going to be you're going to be
leaving with a growth plan and a
business model and a game plan
and clarity cutting edge content that's
going to help give you an edge over the
next year and
you're going to be making connections
with other like-minded purpose-driven
leaders purpose-driven content creators
mission-driven
people that don't just want to build
their influence but also want to make a
major
impact and difference in the world while
doing it so i hope
you could be a part it's a it's a
virtual event you don't gotta fly
anywhere you don't gotta get a hotel
room
and we made it super affordable uh but
make sure to lock in the lowest ticket
price
and you can join us at
growwithvideolive.com
for growth video live 2021.
so i'm curious to know did you know who
dave ramsey was before this episode i
mean i've followed dave ramsey for quite
a while and before i
really jumped on youtube as a content
creator i didn't really even know that
he was posting
that much on youtube and i love his
simple strategy
he's answering simple questions he's
just sitting there it's a
just a forward facing just a regular
shot no b-roll
he's just answering specific questions
and i hope that you can take some of
these tips that we've learned
from dave ramsey and apply it to your
youtube channel
and if you have not gotten your tickets
yet
to grow with video live can you tell how
excited i am when i talk about this
it's coming up really soon august 2021
so make sure you grab your tickets this
is like this is like the coming home
party for all of the think
fam this is where everyone is if you're
a content creator from around the world
and you're getting
serious about growing your youtube
channel maybe you haven't even started
or maybe you're over a hundred thousand
subscribers
maybe you're somewhere in the middle
this is the conference for
you at growth video live 2021 this
virtual experience is going to be
immersive and it's going to be so
much fun along with the fun you are also
going to be taking away
tactics and strategies that you can
apply to your youtube channel
this year and beyond we're serious about
making sure that this content is
fresh and fun and we have so many great
sessions
planned for you so make sure you get
your tickets today at
growthvideolive.com
now if you know the podcast you know
that one of my favorite things
is getting to read your comments over on
our apple
podcast i gotta write this time it's
apple podcast in other episodes
i keep calling it itunes because tony
our producer
has pointed out to me that i'm old and
that itunes is how the old people say it
but it's the apple
apple podcast i get it that's where you
can actually leave your comments and
rate and review this so that other
content creators can know
that this is the spot for them today's
comment comes from kathy at fabulously
frugal kathy said solid concise
actionable yes i love that kathy i love
tuesday mornings because it means i have
more wisdom dropping from think
each podcast generates ideas strategies
and
actionable items a chock full of golden
nuggets a must listen for any youtube
creator who is serious
about creating change on the tubes kathy
i love that review thank you so much for
saying we're chock full
of golden nuggets that makes my heart so
happy
because we put so much time and energy
into making sure that these podcasts are
concise
and that they give you those actionable
steps to take away from
i hope you're enjoying this while you're
driving in your car walking your dog
doing your dishes or folding your
laundry whenever you listen to the
podcast
i'm just so grateful that you've chosen
think to be one of those podcasts that's
influencing your youtube journey
well we are going to head into our next
episode next week but make sure
you get your tickets to grow with video
live and i'll catch you there
next time bye not growing on youtube
learn the newest strategies for getting
views and the best proven ways to make
money
at grow with video live a two day
virtual conference
and you can get your tickets today at
growwithvideolive.com
you